[Music]
nice to see you we were we're a new show
so I'm still kind of playing with how to
come out that time I took my step down
quite gingerly not a keeper okay no more
gingerly stepping okay I'll I'll try
something else hey we found our thing
thanks so much for being here everybody
I'm Pete Holmes this is the Pete Holmes
show I want to talk about this we live
in a we live in a strange modern time
such a strange thing to declare hey if
you noticed we live in this strange
modern time that's not necessary
everybody that's been alive lived in a
modern time nobody alive was ever like I
have a feeling we're in the good old
days it's always been a modern time but
what are the things I want to say I've
noticed about our modern time is I think
that the phrase the word rather
Computers has replaced the phrase I
don't know have you noticed that they
completely don't need I don't know
anymore you can just say computers I was
leaving a movie and there were a lot of
visual effects and the kid said to his
dad he goes dad how did they make the
monsters look so real the dad just
without thinking with computers
Computers no more discussion computers
what he really meant was I don't know
I'll never know
and I'm so scared it's just something
you say when you don't know what else to
say like it is what it is or sorry for
your loss
- real weird grandma go computers but
listen I get it I don't know how
anything works anything I don't know how
it works look at this stage everything
on the stage I'm completely unaware of
how it works the camera how does that
work no idea fake plant how do you how
do you make a fake plant no clue you
guys are like I feel you not caring
you're like yeah we live in a weird and
wonderful time make with the jokes and
that's fine but I wish I knew about more
things cuz you know like scientists are
working on a cellphone battery that's
powered by urine it's exciting a
cellphone battery powered by urine when
I actually heard that news I was so
excited I charged a battery in my pants
that's it's not true and that's a
terrible terrible joke that's an awful
joke that we left in there for a real
moment that we're now experiencing feel
that something's happening right now but
honestly this is why I don't know if
that's amazing is urine a urine powered
batteries that special are they all
urine I don't know what's in a battery
what is in a battery hot sand I'm a
grown man
that's my gas hot sand I think the only
person that knows how batteries work is
the guy who invented them Michael
Michael batteries
that's not his real name
it's Tony Tony Michael batter Tony
Michael TM batteries fake you figured it
out and we all just stopped looking into
it like batteries work we got it who
cares how but it's not just batteries
metal metal where do we get metal this
is not a bit I have no idea where we get
metal is it an earthquake a volcano
every time I see people making metal
they're reaching in to fire with other
meadow my point is if I traveled back in
time I would be completely useless
I would tell all the primitive people of
a better life with modern convenience
but I would have no idea how to bring
them there they'd be like I'd be going
up to like whoa I see you like naked
ladies well the future you can look at
naked ladies listen to this naked ladies
anytime you want for free on the
internet no one in the back what what's
the internet other computers
[Music]